the landlord of corporate clients
including Facebook and Samsung days
being bought by the world's biggest
property investor in a move seen as a
vote of confidence in the UK economy as
those brexit talks get underway
Blackstone is taking a controlling stake
in flexible office space provider the
office group in a move ailing it at half
a billion pounds the company's chairman
Lloyd Dorfman who founded Travelex
and was a major donor to the remain
campaign in last year's referendum he's
reported to have made a profit of around
200 million pounds on the deal he joins
me now so Lloyd before we got on to that
what did you make of the start of Bret's
in negotiations today well I think the
best thing is it started yeah and it's a
year ago this week that we had the
referendum as the early as the previous
speakers were saying and the uncertainty
is in no one's interest and at least we
started the posturing inevitably happens
and you sort of hope that behind the
grandstanding politicians there are some
sort of earnest civil servants and
Eurocrats who had actually trying to put
together something that will work for
everybody the house we said in the
introduction you were a backer of the
remain campaign now that the UK's voted
to leave what's the best in your view
that the UK can get out of out of this
well I mean yeah I speak as someone
who's set up and done business around
the world yeah why would you cut
yourself off from 45% of your market but
my view is we are where we are we've
been through a democratic process and we
have to roll our sleeves up and make the
best of it you know my glass is always
half full and you know we are a trading
nation that has you know done things for
centuries and big change can produce big
opportunity and you know I believe that
we as important as Europe is to the UK
so at the same time Britain represents
an important market for many of the
eurozone countries as well so it's in
their interests equally to to find a way
to trade going forward and I hope that
common sense will prevail and ultimately
everybody will be driven by what's best
for them
now I mean our previous two guests we
had different opinions there on the
merits or otherwise of a transition
agreement presumably you would want to
see one yes I mean it's um look you know
I think it would be extremely optimistic
to hope that everything will be sorted
out and ready for March 2019 I think you
know as the previous speaker said you
know if we can agree the heads of terms
everyone knows the framework of what it
is we're working to then then the the
lawyers and the civil servants can be
the way to you know put the put the
agreement in place but that will take
time and again you know we don't want to
take too long you know even in business
deals with heads of terms' can sometimes
take too long to get sorted out so we
need to get on with it
and I think that's in everybody's
interests including Europe now looking
at today's deal now a lot of people set
post the brexit vote demand for London
office space was going to dry up I mean
this transaction is a big big vote of
confidence in Britain post brexit isn't
it absolutely I mean this is a process
that we started actually back in March a
long long before many of the more recent
dramas have happened politically but
actually going back to this week last
year and the result of referendum we saw
an uptake in inquiries for our flexible
office space the referendum was the
result was good for flexible office
space I think people today what I want
to have more flexibility want to be able
to expand they were to be able to
contract and you know our clients
include not only SMEs and startups and
co-working clients but also major
corporates who really like being in
flexible space and can expand the
contract so we're very bullish and
positive about that now that I mean less
we forget you know you founded Travelex
this is another feather in your cap you
also own double the pastures with me
what gives you the I for a good business
what what makes a good investment
opportunity
I did me know when I was running
Travelex you know people always thought
I was a foreign exchange expert I never
was a foreign exchange expert I'm sort
of attracted to challenger businesses I
like building and creating things I like
taking on so the establishment a bit and
you know so Travelex absolutely took on
the big
banks and became the largest retail
foreign exchange business in the world
the office group you know I said seven
years ago but it's timeless calm and
flexible office space was only going to
go one way and I've been vindicated over
time you know doddle is an amazing
business it's all about you know click
and Collect and in the online shopping
space and the market is only going one
way